thank you
[Music]
[Music]
here
[Music]
good morning currently my dad is getting
some petrol we're on our way to exeter
because officially my uni my medical
school starts tomorrow time is five past
nine am in the morning on a wednesday
see you guys there
[Music]
we're here in access right now to do my
grocery shopping
then
we'll go to my home for the next
academic year
my dad is on his own world
my dad's on his own world is like
unaware of me recording this even he's
just like following me around being on
his phone not helping me but it's fine
because he drove quite a long way and
he's the one who's going to be paying
for this shopping so it's not too bad
[Music]
we're here
this is going to be my room for the next
[Music]
[Music]
how was your summer
it was really chill it was nice to have
a break didn't do basically anything
felt bad by watching your videos that
you were doing revisions so i did
literally five questions in past months
and that was it
just like this
how was your
summer was a bit lazy someone didn't do
much work and ready to get back into a
schedule lara
hi
oh
okay sorry for laughing it's just
because the way you said hi was so sweet
what's the whole thing about doing
revision i've done like yeah i've done
five questions
currently i'm in wrestlers room just to
give you guys an update because my dad
is talking to people in my room but the
plan is basically cleaning all the
wardrobes in my room then unpacking all
the stuff that are in the luggages and
basically organizing them bring them all
into those wardrobes then wrestler
already helps me with my kitchen stuff
and like groceries she already put them
all into the cupboards which was really
helpful so thank you wrestler for that
then we'll just drive down to cornwall
to pick up the rest of my stuff that i
left in my old room so it's going to be
a bit tiring and not complicated because
we drove five hours to get to exeter and
from exeter we go down to cornwall to
get the rest of my stuff then we'll have
to drive back up to exeter again this
was the only way but tomorrow my unit
induction starts at 9 am in the morning
so i'll have to get it all done today
and moving properly today so let's get
this done
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm a gym
[Music]
[Music]
i'm so tired i actually thought i'd be
able to unpack everything that i had and
like move in today properly there's no
way i have an early morning tomorrow so
unpacking all of these will be future
silly hearts problem so i'll go to sleep
now or i'll attempt to go to sleep
because my dad snores a lot
he can't even right now but my dad
snores a lot and he's super tired today
so there is not a high chance of me
falling asleep tonight
good morning i'm just flipping my dad to
his car right now he's going back home
this morning it's currently 6 30am in
the morning
[Music]
i'm back in my room now without my dad i
actually had okay sleep last night
because bless my dad he actually tried
really hard not to snore like whenever
he caught himself snow he would change
his position so he doesn't i'm very
grateful for that thank you baba but now
i can sleep for one half hour before i
need to get up and get ready to go to my
induction at the hospital
i'm hoping you can hear me because it's
raining quite a lot right now at the end
of this day when i unpack all of these
i'll show you guys the end result of
this room two days later this is the
situation in the room i still need to
put a lot of decorations out but at
least all the boxes that were in the
room are gone now and i'm fully unpacked
and this is me
and yeah that's the room tour the view
from my room is not as good as it was
last year but at least i can still see
the sky on the right hand side and it's
not just block of building in front of
me well it kind of is but not on the
right side at least and this is the
other window that looks up to the sky i
just want to come here and say massive
thank you for 1 000 subscribers thank
you so much for your continuous support
and if you haven't subscribed yet
consider to do so i know this video was
a little bit more different than the
rest of my videos but hope you enjoyed
it and medical school vlogs will be
coming up soon and i'll see you in the
next one bye
[Music]